hello Doug Walker here and I'm going to
talk about episode 3 the temple of the a
lousy call I kept a list here the
southern air temple I don't know why the
title always like I'm like what's it
called again what's it called again so I
put it up just in case um and yeah in
this episode the trio they go to a where
Aang is from me it's this giant temple
and the cloud beautiful design love the
design of this place um and if they go
there to try to see if the monks that
train them are still there and the fire
army has gotten to them and that we get
a little bit more insight into his
backstory like he actually is
reincarnated over and over and over and
every single time it does it's into a
different sort of element of a nation or
whatever the water nation or the air
nation and so on so forth so every time
he dies he'll come back as a different
bender um and and that's all find a gun
that that's really great this episode
seemed very much to belong to the prince
though who I just found out was voiced
by Rufio I know it's probably common
knowledge all of you but how does he
still have that voice that's so
impressive how he can still have that
voice because I swore I was like a
teenager doing this but he's a teenager
we did hook so it's very impressive but
anyway so you get more into his
backstory and the relation between him
and and the uncle and also his
interaction sort of with his people and
the general he comes across uh and why
it's so important to him not just why
it's so important but how much time you
spent looking for this avatar character
and if he can actually find this this
guy at this kid and bring him back and
defeat him he might not be an al KS a
more and he might be brought back in and
he can finally regain his honor the
reason the scared is becoming so
fascinating is because it would be so
easy especially in a kids show a
Nickelodeon show on top of that to make
this just the bad guy you can give him a
tragic backstory but there's like little
a few redeeming qualities about him or
he's just a badass
something like that and this is a very
identifiable villain and a lot of that
does come from the uncle who's always by
his side and always trying his best to
support him and keep good sense of humor
too um but this episode more than the
others do you really feel not the
vulnerability cuz I think you got the
vulnerability and the other ones bad but
that's just where you say oh poor tragic
villain we've seen that in Batman a
bunch of our kid shows too that's
nothing new there is a lot of honor to
this character that you discovered by
the end that probably comes from the
uncle uh but it's a good mix between
being very honorable and and very you
know impatient and deceitful and angry
and angsty and it balances out very very
well and at the end of this episode he
has a battle with this general the
general wants to go find the avatar
because he doesn't think the Prince is
capable Yuri lost once uh you know and
his age he's a teenager so he doesn't
think he can do it and he actually they
challenge each other and I guess the
winner can go go find them they to
challenge each other to this firebending
competition it's a great fight great
animation I realize this show has
balance down very well that's what I
think I was trying to say in the last
one is that the balance in this show
when a character is trying to you know
retrace his steps or he's trying to you
know stand up word but stuff is being
thrown at him as is common in the show
you feel when they're off-balance you
feel when they're trying to get back on
their feet and it's very very well done
that's hard to get an animation that
they do very very well and by the end of
this he defeats the general the generals
they you know do it
kill me and stuff like that and he lets
out the finishing blow and for a split
second it got me it then hit me I'm like
wait no it's a kid show and they
wouldn't do that
and sure enough he just hits to the side
of the head um but the character is good
enough and complex enough that even for
a split second a kid show to fool me
like that is impressive um
and I hate using the term kid show
because I always say I'll come out we
should treat them you know more doll
than we we shouldn't talk down to kids
and stuff there is a difference between
children's show and adult shows um but I
think more often than not we try to we
do try to talk down to kids a little too
much uh not all the time I think it
shows eventually made vast improvements
over the years um but this one has a
really good balance and it's getting
really good complex characters not ones
that we've seen a million times it kind
of seems like when Batman came along
everyone was just trying to do Batman
particularly with the characters you
know the tragic villain you feel sorry
for him but oh we're still a bad guy so
whatever they're in that category uh and
this one you really feel the sympathy
for this prince character um and I like
that the general at the end then tries
to attack the prince and the uncle comes
in to save him and it's just it's clear
which of these is the more honorable
ethical character and at that's so
strong because you're so used
particularly in Nickelodeon programming
to just hate the bad guy even if they're
tragic you just hate them and that's it
you're almost kind of rooting for this
guy you see where it's coming from cuz
he's a identifiable it's kind of like
when you're watching the roadrunner and
coyote yeah your room for the roadrunner
but God you feel so bad for the coyote
you watch him just get the damn thing so
it's and that's complex and that's
interesting and I think it's wonderful
that they're incorporating all that um
the one other thing I'll say about this
episode before I sign off is that I'm
really happy they address uh so much um
children's shows and literature is just
just children's media of course a lot of
them star kids and I love the way they
write these kids characters these are
very well written characters um the
brother still gets a dumbell line here
and there but they give him a lot of
honor to which I like he definitely has
his moments as well um but they have the
main cared the special character the one
that's gonna be you know the great hero
whatever and everyone's just like you
know the prophecy or whatever this
a little different this is sort of an
established prophecy that's been going
on for years and years so it's not as
much hey this is just a myth it's like
no this has been proven over and over
that this has happened so um but you
have this special character and everyone
tells the kid you're special you're
gonna be something great you're gonna be
something unbelievable and it's always
the wrong move to do that whenever they
do that Harry Potter I want to smack all
those idiots every time they say you're
gonna be the great one your other chosen
what it shut the up don't you know
what you're doing to this kid and I hate
it when shows do that and this show is
doing the same thing however they
address it they dress in a flashback say
one of the monks saying that it was a
mistake to tell you this at this age and
they don't go into too much detail why
they did but the monk openly
acknowledges we should not have done
that we should have waited until you
were older and just thank you for that
not just for the children watching the
show before the adults watching the show
because there's only so much pressure a
kid can take you know or they can let it
go to their head and I think it's so
smart that they actually address look I
we know we have to sort of do this like
you know everyone can be special given
the chance you know and that's just sort
of you know a routine story but at the
same time they're addressing that it was
not the right thing to do
and that helps because the kid does not
want to be the avatar he does not want
to be the savior of all this you know he
does not want the responsibility and
again that's part of the the problem
with it and they address it so not only
does that create the drama but it shows
where it came from and they show it was
not the right thing to do and I'm really
happy about that I'm really happy that's
addressing that kids it drives me nuts
you know it is same thing in Narnia is
that you know saying the Harry Potter
same thing a secret then - I hate that
and I'm so glad that even though they
aren't technically doing it they're
acknowledging it was a mistake so um
again definitely some very
some fun stuff there playing around with
and and the the episodes is just seem to
be getting stronger and stronger they're
sucking you in more and more so and the
strength of it seems to be the
relationships off the characters and
that's I'm a character guy so I love
that but there's also a good story going
as well with a good mystery and a good
world and I don't you know they call
this thing a lemur that little gizmo
thing I don't know why they don't just
like make up names for these things
yep that's a penguin that is clearly not
a penguin it sure looks like a penguin
but it has an otter and four aren't that
that's really strange uh so but that's
nitpicking I'm really enjoying I've been
enjoying this world I'm enjoying these
designs and but most of all men join the
interaction off these characters so I'm
having a ball with this show and I can't
wait to see episode four and I will see
you there